oi gente boa tarde pessoal paula
sou publicitária trabalho faz bastante
tempo a agência já é quando se trabalha
em agências e tem que ter muitas ideias
para várias marcas nem obviamente daí um
dia fiquei pensando poxa porque a gente
não pode aproveitar o dinheiro todo que
essas marcas investem pra fazer alguma
coisa mais interessante para nós
consumidores e aí foi daí que partiu
essa idéia do marketing de convivência a
gente usar o marketing das empresas pra
pra fazer mais as pessoas vivem
histórias mais bacanas com as marcas
para conectar as marcas de uma forma
mais interessante do que só um comercial
de tv que na verdade não significa muita
coisa então é o marketing favor da
proximidade das experiências verdadeiras
de não tratar a gente como se a gente
fosse só espectadores ou leitores de
jornal né que a gente tem lembranças e
conexões com essas marcas é eu trouxe
aqui algumas inspirações na verdade é
que se fala mais importante é uma
maquiagem de convivências idéia toda é
resultou na régua naciri que essa idéia
que eu trouxe pra mostrar pra vocês que
nada mais é do que é uma facilitadora de
processos entre coletivos que são
pessoas que já conhecem muito
profundamente a cidade que estudam isso
e as marcas ea gente à cidade né pra
fazer coisas bacanas
os coletivos já estão mostrando muitas
coisas legais pra gente assim nessa
nessa direção
então eu trouxe aqui algumas inspirações
na verdade quando eu mandei essa
apresentação isso aqui não é daqui do
brasil é de fora mas quando eu mandei
aconteceu uma coisa muito legal seis
devem conhecer o largo da batata em são
paulo certo
aquilo foi pensada de maneira um pouco
grotesca sindhotéis cantava bonitinha
até porque eles fizeram uma praça
gigantesco espaço gigantesco que podia
ser aproveitado para um espaço de
convivência para as pessoas né curtirem
e ficou movimentado bizarro que não
serve pra nada
um coletivo teve que ir lá fazer
recentemente design ok é um coletivo
bárbaro
um coletivo de designers para colocar um
jardim fez um jardim maravilhoso com
banquinhos e tal e agora as pessoas têm
um espacinho ali finalmente quer dizer
isso poderia ter né
vindo do poder público ou de alguma
máquina fim de alguém que realmente
tivesse dinheiro para investir nisso
vieram dele estão os coletivos também
muitas gerações pra gente olha que idéia
mais simples do mundo é isso numa praça
se não me engano no jardim edite o
coletivo rua que fez isso pra ensinar
crianças né na reciclagem quer dizer é a
adequação ao público também não adianta
você colocar as latinhas lá em cima como
é que faz
então eles aproveitaram e fizeram suas
latinhas divertidas farol civil que
legal agora dá porque esse click na
praça as cores os bonequinhos mostrando
pra vocês como é que faz etapa
também temos esse eu não sei se conhecem
esse projeto curativos urbanos alguém
conhece é muito legal eles usam esses
bandeiras coloridos para mostrar onde é
que tem buracos nem cuidar
vão cuidar lembrar a gente que a gente
tem que cuidar dessa a gente não na
prefeitura da cidade onde a gente vive
e aqui eu trouxe por exemplo de
mobilidade vou falar rapidinho desse
aqui vocês conhecem o que o ônibus passa
aqui é muito legal esse projeto é um
canal foi um golpe em ninguém na que na
verdade são adesivos
a idéia é super simples porque os pontos
de ônibus na cidade de são paulo não são
um mostro que o ônibus passo naquele
lugar
ou seja as pessoas que não sabem ficam
lá
adivinhando essa idéia é simples você
coloca é é um adesivo que kaká é
colaborativo pessoas que sabem que o
ônibus passam a falar do avaí e anota um
lance agressivo
esse é um projeto do linkão
o instituto mobilidade road na pracinha
da oscar freire é também é em parceria
com a incorporadora na língua e se essa
pracinha as incorporadoras estão nesse
movimento foi quem tá é quem está
começando é assim a fazer esse movimento
jim de convivência de investir na cidade
acho que porque é construindo a cidade
então estou aproveitando para fazer
alguma coisa de bom
e aí como é que a gente replica nessas
idéias dos coletivos aqui eu trouxe dois
exemplos de fora porque a gente não tem
muitos exemplos aqui é de como as marcas
podem se conectar a essas idéias
essa é uma idéia muito simples da coca
cola era um caminhão que trazia essa
graminha numa praça tipo largo da batata
que não tinha nada e aí as pessoas pra
ganhar é o mal tinha de coca tinham que
tirar os sapatos e aproveitar um pouco
fazer uma pausa no dia
esse é um projeto da ibm que chama
mateus cites e aproveitou grande assim
ela jantou no grande isso aqui eu só
trouxe para ilustrar na verdade os
anúncios que eles fizeram anúncios em
que chamaram de anúncios inteligentes
então não era simplesmente um anúncio
que podiam sentar em um banquinho aqui o
que você se proteger da chuva enfim
idéias bacanas que conectam as pessoas
com a cidade
aqui no brasil a gente começa a ver um
movimento bem saquinho de algumas marcas
que estão começando a entender a
importância da qualidade da cidade é
bacana né as pessoas verem e aí estamos
começando a se unir ao poder público pra
transformar alguns lugares a gente tem
acho que o melhor exemplo disso lançou
esse prefeito vai aproveitando bike
samba
foi uma coisa muito legal que o itaú fez
né recentemente um jeito maravilhoso de
explorar a marca de se conectar com as
pessoas e de fazer uma coisa muito legal
pra cidade né
mobilidade é que o carro acabaram sendo
criadas um monte de ciclovias por conta
dessa idéia e do bike samba e aí eu
trouxe dois projetos é que se começou a
fazer nada são os dois únicos agentes
os dois sobre os dois únicos de muitos
eu espero é esse foi um projeto que a
gente fez como incorporadora de são
paulo chamada idéias arvus não sei quem
conhece aqui é que é uma incorporadora
que pensa um pouco diferente porque as
incorporadoras
enfim quando vou construir prédios elas
não pensam muito no que está acontecendo
no entorno delas no esquecem de de de
que o prédio ele não é só de quem vai
morar de quem vai conviver com ele né
não tem sua mãe como é q qq o prédio vai
se conectar com as pessoas então é ainda
zarvos pensar um pouquinho diferente
então ele se construir um prédio que não
devolver alguma coisa de positivo para
aquele daquele espaço onde eles estavam
construindo e esse projeto
ele foi feito ao lado de um prédio na
ideia as árvores
essa é uma pracinha que tinha lá que
ninguém usava muito sim
aqui tem muito uso é porque também há
gente eu acho que a gente não tem essa
cultura muito de se apropriar dos
espaços públicos não é que a gente tem
que são nossos
no brasileiro a gente não tem muito o
costume de lá pra cá como tem muito nem
em outros países assim aproveita praças
parques etc
muito também porque não tem muito o que
fazer não terminar a prefeitura não
investe muito nisso mas agora estou lá
ea gente antes de fazer qualquer coisa a
gente pensou bom vamos falar como quem
vai usar esse espaço né não é
simplesmente java melhorar praça deixar
essa bonitinha como a gente quer que as
pessoas usem a praça então vamos vamos
falar com quem está morando ali pra ver
o que essas pessoas fazem como elas
podem usar melhor esse espaço
então a gente ficou então com alguns
coletivos é ajudando foi é o café na rua
o conexão cultural são dois com estilos
bastante atuantes ea gente fazia várias
e várias reuniões com a comunidade para
tentar entender como que seria na praça
mais legal para elas
já essa praça hoje é foi feita junto com
as crianças de uma escola aqui perto
foi um um projeto que envolveu muita
coisa na educação design e hoje a praça
meio que se auto sustenta porque é essa
esses gráficos que vocês estão vendo
eles são feitos em painéis de madeira
que depois são vendidos ea renda
revertida para a própria trás foi uma
coisa muito bacana e esse aqui foi um
projeto bem interessante de uma
incorporadora também chamada uma é que
que na verdade queria se conectar com
seus vizinhos
nunca vi isso acontecer não sei se
alguém viu me diga eles queriam na
verdade é começar o processo de fundação
é que é o processo mais chato do da
construção que atormenta bastante
vizinhos e eles queriam avisar os
vizinhos a eu vou começar a fazer isso
vou te atrapalhar mas eu tô aqui pra
qualquer coisa e aí a gente é muito
legal essa iniciativa deles a gente
também foi pesquisar quem eram esses
vizinhos serão enfim jovens idosos como
eles eram a gente descobriu que era pé
para a mão na vizinhança bastante idosa
ea gente resolveu fazer uma coisa muito
simples que foi resgatar um pouco essa
coisa da convivência entre vizinhos que
eu acho que a gente quase não tem hoje
né gente num não fala com os nossos
vizinhos dos apartamentos não tenha mais
essa relação que tinha antes
e aí a gente não resgatou esta relação a
uma coisa muito simples é um bolinho
caseiro que a gente levou para cada um
deles com uma cartinha dizendo
exatamente isso olha seu vizinho mas eu
quero ter uma boa relação com eu acho
atrapalhar por algum tempo e tal mas eu
quero ter uma boa relação com você e foi
uma coisa muito engraçada porque essas
pessoas
isso mostrou pra gente como é que a
gente não está muito acostumado a
gentileza de outras pessoas sabe
os moradores ficaram chocados assim
ficava perguntando pra gente mas que não
sendo esse prédio
vai fazer uma coisa minha casa está
caindo o que eles achavam que a gente
estava se desculpando pela banda coisa e
não que a gente estava na verdade se
apresentando e e sendo simplesmente
gentil não é só samba pra gente como a
gente realmente não está acostumado mais
parece com a gentileza do outro
eu trouxe é uma parte bem pequenininha
da pesquisa mas acho que mostra como a
gente está evoluindo como o consumidor é
e não querendo também comprar de
qualquer marca sabe já estavam avaliando
um pouquinho melhor essa escolha
essa acho que a pergunta mais crucial
por isso que eu trouxe que mostra que a
grande maioria das pessoas
trocaria marca habitual para o máximo
similar que provar alguma coisa boa para
a cidade
então eu acho que a gente também está
num caminho é pedindo isso das marcas né
pra acabar com uma frase que eu acho que
resume bastante isso que eu estava
falando que civilização antes de mais
nada à vontade de convivência acho que
em algum momento a gente perdeu a
vontade de conviver né e à convivência
diz muito sobre respeito educação na
noite de quarta quando você para de
conviver com as pessoas
isola se acaba esquecendo coisas básicas
né em algum momento a gente se perdeu aí
na vontade de conviver e deixou de ser
um pouco é de ficou menos civilizado né
mas acho que a gente está numa crescente
eu acho que a gente consegue conectar
que essa idéia da rms conectar pessoas
que estão afim de ver uma cidade melhor
que estão a fim de ser pessoas melhores
né pra ver fazer umas das melhores
marcas que possam investir nessas idéias
muito bacanas desses coletivos que a
gente vai conseguir viver em uma cidade
primas bacana
obrigado a gente